maana
room he tells us this hadith
he works on it
and he has a poem called the man who looked back
while on his way to the fire
and he's basing this on this hadith
so he says the guardian angels
who used to walk unseen
before him and behind him
have now become
visible and they drive him to the
like prison guards,
which is true.
How many angels do you live with?
You have,
you have,
they're here or here, wherever they may be.
They are there.
You never saw them.
You have other angels that are with you constantly
that protect you, that help you, that do other things for you.
Over a hundred,
okay? But you don't see them.
And
we don't even pay attention to them.
We forget about them totally.
We must never disbelieve in them because that would be kufur.
But on the day of judgment, you will see them.
When you die,
your two angels
and
sit at your grave
and they ask God to forgive you.
Okay? And they will be res when you're resurrected, they will be there, too.
So these people now see their angels who lived
out the miserable lives of these two men as they disobeyed God and they did terrible
things.
Now they've become like policemen who drive them to the fire.
So you didn't believe in us.
Okay. Well, let's see if you believe in us now.
And then one of them looks back
wistfully.
Jalaladin Molana. He says his tears
fall from his eyes like the soft rain of autumn before the winter.
The rain that's not going to grow anything cuz the summer's over.
Just a mere hope,
a tear.
What does he have but that?
And then in the hadith it says God sends the angels to say why did he
look back?
So
also tells us that and then the man says, "God, my lord,
I am a hundred times
a hundred times worse
than you declared me to be at my judgment.
I deserve nothing but the fire.
But
I had in this wretched heart
a hope that never died,
that somehow
you would show me your loving kindness.
I turn to you.
He's speaking. That's why it's about words.
I turn to you and to your pure grace,
not to my actions.
I trust in you, not in me.
I'm nothing. So then God tells the angels, "Bring him back.
Forgive him.
Put him in the garden.
He never lost hope in me,
even as he walks to the fire."
It's a beautiful story.
very meaningful story.
And we know that the believers who go to the fire, may we not be among
them.
And they are a lot.
They are hordes of believers because most believers never figure it out.
They live their lives in
neglect and heedfulness.
But the believer will be released
from the fire.
and you will wish and may you never go that you had never gone.
May we not go there.
May we realize
what this dean is about and wake up while we are here
is
um but nevertheless
um you know this man is among the first
who will be released from that and he didn't even go in
but he had that hope.
So
uh the tongue then is an amazing thing
and use it as that amazing thing that it is
and it's also very dangerous.
Um
the tongue is so easy to use
right
almost every one of us some people speak more easily than others.
Some have great facility, others don't have the same facility.
But we can all use our tongues generally speaking, unless there's some obstruction
and the tongue is small in size.
It's easy to use, especially if you're speaking your mother tongue.
Um,
you know, so we usually use our tongues
without thinking about what we're doing.
And that's a very disastrous thing to do.
Therefore, as a rule,
our tongues are the most disobedient
of all the human faculties that we have.
They rattle on.
They paddle on.
They never get tired.
You know, they they rush in where angels fear to tread.
This is because the the tongue is so easy to use,
so easy to unleash.
And often,
especially when we're not talking about what's good,
we don't get tired of talking.
It costs so little for us to keep it working,
the tongue.
And therefore, most human beings give it no attention.
They pay it no attention.
We take lightly whatever we say
and therefore the tongue is Satan's
most successful ploy
to use against us in guiding us astray.
The prophet said saiam.
So the blessed prophet said sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the servant of gods
iman
will not be
right
won't be the way it's supposed to be won't be straight it won't be sound
until
his or her
heart
is right
is sound
and his or her
heart
will not be right or sound
until the tongue is sound,
until the tongue is right.
So, you've got to get that straight.
And this is one of the most important things for you.
No doubt you do that already, but you want to do it all the time.
Think about what you are speaking about.
Be careful about what you say.
There is safety in silence.
Wrong speech hurts you.
Wrong speech weighs you down.
Bad speech harms your heart
and it also chips away at your iman.
Even though the words that you speak seem to be as light as feathers,
they seem to depear
in thin air, but they don't.
That's not the way reality is set up.
you need to learn about the metaphysics
of this world.
The way this world is really put together.
Um
so
uh speech is very very important
and
um
too much talk
fills your heart with worries.
That's the least it does.
You have worries.
One of the best way that you ways that you can overcome your worries is silence.
Invoke the name of God.
Recite the Quran.
Sit and be silent.
Think about God.
Think about the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
But when you talk and talk and talk and talk and talk and talk and talk
and call up this person and Twitter that person and text this person, your heart becomes
filled with trouble
and worries.
And of course, there are times when you have to talk.
There are times when you have to tell others about the misery that you may feel
and the situation that you're in.
But you pick those people carefully
and you pick your words carefully.
Okay, don't think that you can remove your troubles and your anxieties by just talking and
talking and talking.
Tawus,
his name means the peacock
and he was one of the greatest of the successors.
May Allah be pleased with them all.
And he was from the Yemen.
The Yemen is a beautiful part of the world.
May God protect it in this time
of
horrible calamities
and
disasters that is sweeping the world everywhere.
The Tu said, "My tongue
is a wild beast
sever.
If I were to let it loose, it would eat me alive."
Are those beautiful words?
Those are the words of a of Allah.
Look how few they are.
But they are worth saying a thousand times.
Abdullahbn Mass, may Allah be pleased with him,
he said, "Nothing
is more deserving
of a long prison sentence
than your tongue.
You need to put your tongue in prison for a long time.
So do I.
It deserves that.
Be careful about what you say.
Maana Abu Bakr is
the greatest of all human beings after the prophets and the messengers.
What did he used to do?
He kept a pebble on his tongue.
What a silly thing to do.
No,
you could buy here in Turkey a precious stone.
Right here in the market in Ca.
could get a tiger's eye
or something else,
polish it and put it on your tongue
and then when you want to speak, you can't talk.
You have to go, "Well, just a minute."
But before you do that, think
may Allah be pleased with him.
He did that so he cannot speak
without thinking.
He's got to listen to you carefully.
There's a pebble in his mouth.
I wish I had that pebble.
It must be very blessed.
And then before he speaks, he takes it out.
Okay? And this is the itchi
of one of the greatest human beings who ever was.
So that what he speaks is right.
Let's go back to
the peacock,
great successor, great,
great of Allah.
He says,
So he said
he
we can say she as well in Arabic whenever we use the male gender we always
imply the female.
If we say brother we mean sister.
If we say brotherhood we mean sisterhood and our fukah talk about that.
Unless
we mean to say something specifically related to one gender or another then we specify that.
But he says that he or she
has no
sound intellectual
understanding
of the dean
who does not guard
his or her tongue.
So
when we just talk as most of us do
and most of our brothers and sisters do
often raising our voices
right then it means that we don't have much intellect
and we have no intellectual understanding of the dean we haven't grasped it so may we
grasp it
may Allah be pleased with him who was one of the greatest of the successors
He's really the master you know of the successors along with
Parani who's sort of between the companions and the successors
but he said they
meaning
the companions
and the successors
and this is also a hadith
they used to say
the tongue of the believer is behind his heart.
The tongue of the believer is behind
his heart or her heart.
If he wants to say something,
he reflects on it in his heart
and then if it's good, his heart lets him say it.
Go ahead and speak.
It's okay.
But the tongue of the hypocrite,
he that's and this is often what they do.
They they compare the believer with the hypocrite.
Who was the great believer in Medina?
The one who prayed all night.
The one who fasted every other day.
The one who recited the Quran day and night.
Most of them did that.
But it's the one who met his brother with joy on his face and a smile
and no duplicity in his heart and no hypocrisy.
And they believed that the the frowning Muslim who can never smile, who's never really happy
with his brothers and sisters, has the stamp of hypocrisy on his face?
How many Muslims are like that today?
They don't smile.
They frown.
They're not happy to see anyone.
They have a bad opinion of everyone.
A lot of them believe that we are Muslims for sure.
But I don't know about the rest of these people.
They all sayahillah.
They all say Muhammad.
If God
is content
to create weak people as his servants
who have failings whom he will guide and forgive.
You're not content to be their brother.
You're not content to be their sister.
If you can't serve the people that God created
and love them,
you think you can serve God.
That doesn't work like that.
It doesn't work like that.
And this is why for the Sahabah to have a clean heart, a good heart,
a heart that is filled with joy
at the believer,
whether that believer is the best or the worst.
and to help the person who needs to be helped.
You know, this is the sign of belief.
But the believer's tongue is behind his or her heart.
The hypocrites tongue is in front of his heart.
This is what Alassi
said. This is what the companions believed.
Who taught them?
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
If he is concerned about anything or bothered by anything or perplexed by anything,
he blurts it out.
His tongue just says it
and he does not use his or her heart to reflect on it.
Okay, this is the way politicians are.
That's why they did I really say that well well um you know I mean if
you speak the truth you don't have to worry about what you said.
you know, if you will put your tongue behind your heart, you don't have to worry
about what you said, but they're not like that.
So, may Allah enable us, you know, to
um follow this guidance.
Thank you.
Um so then we begin to speak a little bit about the secrets of silence
because silence is your friend.
Silence is your gift
and speech must come out of silence.
And when silence is the way it should be
filled with reflection
filled with thought silence pollinates your intellect.
And then silence gives you beautiful speech.
Silence is golden.
Speech is silver.
Silence is
gathering.
Speech is
separation.
Speech
silence is power.
Speech is weakness.
Doesn't mean that it's going to always be weak.
And it doesn't mean that it's always going to be silver.
Might be gold,
but it's got to come out of silence.
How could Alassi
think of these things to say?
How could Paw
How could Abdullahbas
think of these things to say?
Because they live in a world of silence that pollinates their intellects.
They think about things
and they speak little.
And then when they speak that speech is worth recording until the day of judgment.
The prophet said,
"Whoever keeps silence
will be safe.
Whoever keeps silence will be safe.
You will succeed.
So learn to be silent."
And again, we live in the world of plastic words.
We
live under the rain
of plastic words.
No denotations,
a thousand connotations.
They change like styles.
Okay? And we talk and we talk and we talk.
The talk show.
We say whatever we want.
We text,
you know, we Twitter.
Okay? So you have got to learn to bring this under control
and then your intellect
will grow
and you will understand your religion with your heart and your intellect.
And this is not stupid silence.
This is the silence of men and women who have oceans in their hearts.
The prophet said, "Sallam
Whoever
would be
made happy, filled with joy
to be safe
on the day of judgment and in this world as well.
Let him keep silence.
So you've got to learn to do this.
And again in our cultures it's often difficult because
especially in some of our cultures like that of many Americans
if you don't talk they think you don't like them.
In fact they think that you dislike them and that you
want to hurt them.
You know um this is just the way their culture is.
They're not all like that.
But the thing is this is why also you have to learn another prophetic sunnah which
no doubt you do.
Smile
and let that smile
radiate the beauty of your heart
because the smile also speaks for you without saying words.
So I do like you.
I like to be in your presence.
You do have value to me but I don't have a lot of things to say.
And uh we need to do be able to reduce speech.
Often even if we're driving in the car together and you're silent and he's silent and
the other person's silent, it's like what's wrong?
You know, who's going to break the ice?
Well, there's no ice.
Maybe we're all doing,
you know, and in the traditional Muslim world, there would be no problem with that whatsoever.
But for us, it puts us on edge because we live in this word, this world
where we
diffuse
the problems we have, the anxieties we have by meaningless speech.
Go,
have you ever been to a club,
an athletic club, YMCA,
whatever it is, and listen to how the people talk.
Usually, they're just diusing
their anxieties. They're not saying anything.
So,
um, the prophet said, "Sallam,
he said,
peace be upon him, shall I not inform you
about the easiest type of worship?"
I'd like to know that.
The easiest type of worship.
How long did you stand in Ramadan?
Did your feet hurt?
Yes.
Did your legs hurt?
Did you get tired?
Of course you did.
So did I.
We're not supposed to be like that, but we're weak.
Is there an easier type of worship?
We'll also do that one.
So he said, "Can I let me tell you about the easiest form of worship
and the most convenient for the body?
Keeping silence.
Not hard to do.
Keeping silence as an act of worship
and having good character.
Deal with the people, all people,
whoever they are, with good character.
What a beautiful thing to do.
The prophet said,
the prophet said, sallallahu alaihi wasallam, whoever believes in God in the last day,
you believe in God, you believe in the last day.
It's real.
When is the last day going to be?
What are the signs of the day of judgment?
Well, that's important.
When is your last day?
When is your day of judgment?
That's practical.
Whether we are round to see the final hour or not, not too likely
and not extremely important.
But I have a last day that is coming and so do you.
That's what counts.
Don't forget that.
It could be the next five minutes.
It could be tomorrow.
And it doesn't matter how old you are or young.
not even how healthy you might be.
Okay, so that's what counts.
We believe in the last day.
And whoever believes in God in the last day,
then let him speak
good
or keep quiet
or be quiet.
Prophet said,
"Oh,
may God show special mercy to a person, a servant of God who speaks and wins
great bounty like Maana."
Okay.
Um or the zakar,
the person who invokes God
or the person who recites the Quran
or who keeps silence and is safe.
The sal
may Allah be pleased with them and make us pleased with them and let us benefit
from them.
of all the things the upright
Muslims of the first generations
cared about.
Was it giving fatwa?
Was it giving fat?
Was it saying this is haram?
This is haram.
This is
this is
No, that was about two dozen of them that did that.
And they regarded it to be an affliction that they had to bear because somebody's got
to clarify the law.
you know she's one of those Abdullahb
is another Omar is another
is another and there are others
okay but most of them they don't want to talk about that because they don't want
to be judged
but they all know about the heart
they all every single one of them knew about the heart
and this is something I im gazali
makes really clear throughout the whole of the
which is one of the greatest treasure measures that God has left for human beings.
They are people who cared about their hearts.
But they would say
silence
s
keeping silence
brings together for you
two excellent traits.
Salama in your dean
soundness and safety in your religion and
the ability to understand your companion.
You know it's very important to understand your brother or your sister.
That is one of your obligations.
This religion is sincere
behavior towards others.
Counsel.
How can you give counsel to people you don't understand?
How can you give counsel to people you don't know?
If we learn to be quiet, then we begin to learn.
Listen to what they say.
Listen to what they have to say.
Don't be ready to talk
and talk when the time comes to talk.
So this is also one of the gifts of the secrets of silence.
You begin to understand other people.
You begin to have compassion for them and empathy with them.
And solitude also helps us to do that.
And you should always have a time of solitude.
Even if you're a housewife who has many children and many responsibilities,
you need a time for yourself when you are silent
and when you can just be quiet.
So silence also enables us to develop this trait of silence.
Solitude, I'm sorry,
solitude.
And this is the kind of silent silence that pollinates your intellect
and purifies your heart and removes your troubles and removes your anxieties and gives you
dignity. War
is an incredible quality that you have in you because of that precious good that is
in you that you've got locked in a safe place
and it enables you to teach and to live
tawa the fear of God
and the consciousness of God.
Let's end here
with
um a beautiful statement from
the great Khaled
Abd Aziz.
May Allah be merciful to him.
And when Omar died, a sui tells us that when they buried Omarbd
Aziz in Damascus, they saw a piece of paper
up in the air
going back and forth and it came down and down and down and down until it
settled on his grave.
And they picked it up and it says,
"You are free of the fire.
You are free of the fire.
Aziz
was one of the greatest of all and again this is a letter he wrote to
ali
to Imam Malik
you know to Abu Hanifh
and to uh you know the other
great jurists of his time
um Abuhanifh received this letter Alah
received it and many others alasim Iban Muhammad and others so he wrote to them his
letter is two lines
and he said As for what follows,
whoever calls death
to mind frequently
will be content with little in this world.
Im Shafi, may Allah be pleased with him, is one of the greatest of the great.
Immafi
once went into a situation
in Medina
where
questions about
involuntary manslaughter
were brought to him
and he answered them all.
And then he was given gifts from the people of Korasan and the gifts from the
people of Iraq and others.
And um
he began to cry.
And in one story they say Imam Malik was there and he said why are you
crying? They said it's because of fear of the world isn't it?
And Imam Ashafi said yes
I did this for the sake of God and they give me this treasure in place
of it. Who will protect my heart?
And of course I im Malikaf
Abu Hanifh Ahmed Hanbal may Allah be pleased with them.
They attain the heights they did because they can keep that world out of their hearts.
But he sends this to people like them
because the
in particular
he or she has got to beware of the world.
So he says call death to mind
all the time and then you'll be happy with little and you'll be able to give
away what you were given.
Then he says whoever regards his speech
to be part of his action,
we might say voluntary action.
In other words, this is that's what your speech is.
It's a voluntary act.
It's a speech act.
When you stood up to pray in Ramadan and
you knew that was a voluntary act and you did it because you believed in God
and you did it because you wanted his reward and you knew it's hard,
but I'll do it every night.
And it gets easier.
Okay? And we want to listen to the whole Quran.
It's not easy.
We know that's an act.
I chose to do that act.
It's voluntary
just like giving in charity, going to Umrah, going to pilgrimage.
So these things we do, we know these are acts.
We're very careful.
So he said never forget
that your speech is also a voluntary act.
And he says when you know that then your speech will be little
except for what concerns you.
And they say that vikar
the invocation of god
is the fasting of the tongue
you know. So if you don't have a pebble
and even if you have a pebble you can take it out and you can do
vikar invocation
the remembrance of god invoking.
You have the power to call upon the name of god.
What a special person you are.
And god will mention you in the seventh heaven.
Okay. And again, who are you?
Son of Adam, daughter of Adam.
You know, you have got to learn who you are and you've got to live for
that and you've got to realize that.
And if you do that, you change the world.
You change the world.
So,
um I think our time might be up.
Yep. It is.
It is
time up. Okay.
So, we've got these little questions
and I will take them with me and uh I think we have a session tomorrow
and maybe the next day we have two
and we have another day that will also be two.
I think we have nine in all
and uh inshallah we'll try to make good use of it.
I hope we have time for questions and I'll try to look at these
and um
inshallah Allah bless you and protect you.
Amen. Amen. Amen.
Um,
it's a great honor to be in this city
and it's an especially great honor to be in this city with people like you
and may Allah make these blessed days and
um, you know, may this be
one of the great transformations of our lives.
You know that um, we have a lot of work to do.
Okay.
You know, you live in a time
the last 200 years
everything was done
to destroy this religion that is thinkable and unthinkable.
The last 200 years have been the real test.
A weak ummah then shattered by tests and fitness and innovations
in every way at a time when we are at our worst
and our weakest.
And yet, you know, this um
is amazing
and it has in it people like you.
And uh we have got to
bring it back to life in our hearts
and to take that gift to our friends and our neighbors and to people everywhere in
the world.
That's what you have to devote your life to.
And may Allah give you long life.
And may he enable you to use your life really well no matter what you do.
Amen.